[Music]
i'll come back to the next episode of
what's up prof
good day walter good day young martin
how are you doing
i'm good and you i'm fine um
we'd like to start off before
we begin with our discussion just to
give some clarity
on the answering of questions yes
and we just want to make it clear to the
viewers we really appreciate
all questions and all comments
but it's humanly impossible to get
through to
and answer all the questions that's
absolutely
impossible it will i think if you have
to answer
the questions you get in one day it can
keep you quite busy for a year
it's not possible so we just want to say
that
we try our best to answer as many as
possible and that's why we also
do questions and answer whatsapp profs
and also take a look at the links
we provide and there's also questions
and answer
database on our website that's also
posted and everything so
just to get some clarity for people on
that but if we can we do take this note
yes
yeah so i'll open for with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for bringing us together again thank you
lord that we can
have these discussions in the times that
we live in
we ask again that you bless us with this
discussion and also enlighten our minds
with the holy spirit
in jesus name amen amen
well martin today we're talking about
the roman church and
it's not something that you know
we cherish but it's something that
is necessary and in the light of
events currently i mean we've spoken
about it so much
and people say oh there they go again
but people don't get it
no they just don't get it it's a very
serious
issue and like you said people probably
it doesn't seem that they get what
is this whole roman catholicism
church about about yes and
what you this whole
discussion actually came about very
quickly
and it was again about
speeches that we've come across that
biden and trump made yes we need to look
at this
and we'll start off with the video and
then we'll see
where it takes us and why we have to go
in this direction it's not a popular
message that we have
and it is an ancient message
and it is necessary that people don't
forget
yes so let's have a look at some of the
speeches that have been made
recently at prayer breakfasts
and at special occasions especially
before the elections
so these are brand new and they are very
current
so let us look at the issue
i know for me my catholic faces help me
through the darkness
as i've had to bury pieces of my soul
deep in the earth
and eventually found purpose to live a
life
worthy of those i lost and throughout my
life in public service
i've been guided by the tenets of
catholic social doctrine
that cuts across all confessional face
what you do to the least among us you do
unto me
we have an obligation to one another we
cannot serve ourselves at the expense of
others
we have a responsibility to future
generations
and that's the charge before us today
and that sense of hope and possibility
reminds me of the first time i met
pope francis in 2013 when i had the
privilege of attending his inauguration
at the vatican
when i greeted him he said mr vice
president you're always welcome here
he was really sending a message to the
world to put out a welcome sign
on the front door of our church two
years later
president obama and i welcomed him at
the white house at that same
moment we shared a sense of hope and
possibility together for me
it came in a very personal moment a very
tough time in the life of my family
our son beau had just died a few months
earlier
but pope francis took the time
to meet with my entire family to help us
see the light through the darkness
i live in an amazing country we all live
in amazing country
where an irish catholic kid like me from
scranton pennsylvania
would one day befriend the jesuit pope
but that's who we are as a country where
anything is possible
when we care for one another when we
look out for one another
when we keep the faith may god bless you
all
i may god bless america and may god
protect our troops
well that was the biden speech
this is normally a very public event and
normally
the cardinal is present but this year it
had to be a zoom
event it's fascinating to me
that the biden camp is just as
religiously orientated as the other camp
you know we're always inclined to think
that
the trump campaign and the trump camp
is closer to the king of the north
but in many respects the biden camp is
closer than the trump camp because he
mentioned
the catholic social doctrine exactly and
the democratic party
has a manifesto and a vision
which is much closer to the catholic
social doctrine than is the trump camp
yes so the king of the north
sets in both and it doesn't really
matter who
wins the ascendancy of the king of the
north philosophy
can just as well be in both parties
so it doesn't matter at all who wins the
election
the issue of prophecy will be
fulfilled it's quite important to notice
that
because it doesn't matter which one will
win
the dictates of rome
will be enforced absolutely and he's on
the same page
biden is more on the page in terms of
social doctrine i just read
the pope's latest uh
encyclical on brotherly fraternity
i must say that i was the place about 90
pages long
and i went through it with the tooth
come and highlight it
many places basically it's a rewrite
of rerum novarum
on catholic social doctrine and if you
read it carefully it sounds
so so sweet and flowery and
loving and accommodating and kind
but it is basically aligned
against every tenant of the bible
and it is literally against the
commandments of god
but people won't notice it because the
language is so
carefully chosen it's like the
joint document on their declaration of
justice clarification by faith yeah
we'll
this is the same type of language at the
same time
they know how to disguise and what was
interesting for me
i don't know if it's maybe i'm seeing
something too much in it
in it but that he specifically said
it's um an honor to have a jesuit
pope as if as a friend why would he want
to
why would he say that yeah bring out
that it's a jesuit
pope yes well let's look at the next
ones
it is a profound honor to address the
75th annual al smith dinner
for generations this wonderful event has
been a revered
institution in new york and new york
life
i fondly remember attending with my
father a long time ago i was a young man
but never forgot it
this organization's incredible tradition
of catholic charity
exemplifies the very best not only of
this city
but of this country i want to thank
cardinal dolan a very special man for
his extraordinary stewardship of the
archdiocese
and for his deep dedication to god and
to our nation
i also want to thank him for all of the
help he's given me
and so many things in so many different
ways thank you very much cardinal we
very much appreciate it
and of course the catholic community and
the men and women of the new york
archdiocese
answered the call and frankly answered
it
like nobody else could in catholic
schools hospital shelters soup kitchens
and food pantries
you served with the supreme devotion to
your fellow citizens
you showed the world the essence of the
catholic faith i've known about it for a
long time i lived right next to a
magnificent catholic church as jesus
christ said in the gospel
everyone will know that you are my
disciples
if you love one another as president i
want to thank the catholic community for
the magnificent generosity you showed in
america's hour of need
from the very beginning of our republic
catholics have uplifted
and enriched our nation beyond measure
catholics like
charles carroll helped secure american
independence
women like saint elizabeth ann seton
founded a movement that
created thousands of schools and lifted
children
out of poverty and the great al smith
the original happy warrior that's what
he was he was a happy warrior i know it
well
i consider myself to be a happy warrior
but it's not so easy at these times
but he was a happy warrior of american
politics he spent
his life fighting for hard-working
americans and battling the anti-catholic
prejudice
that you see even today coming out of
the democrat party
today this amazing group continues that
proud tradition
of faithful service your work reminds us
of an essential truth
in this country civil society and
especially our religious institutions
are an essential foundation of american
freedom
our nation is strong because of
catholics and frankly
people of all faiths that is why as
president one of my top priorities is to
defend religious liberty
and the cherished role of faith and
faith-based organizations in our
national life to protect your god-given
rights i was recently honored to
nominate
one of our most brilliant legal minds
judge
amy coney barrett to the united states
supreme court and that was an
honor indeed she is a proud graduate of
the university of notre dame law school
where her professor one of the most
respected anywhere in the country said
she was the single greatest student
he has ever had in his class we will not
stand for any
attacks against judge barrett's faith
anti-catholic
bigotry has absolutely no place in the
united states of america
it predominates in the democrat party
and we must do something immediately
about it
like a republican win and let's make it
a really big one
to support the noble mission of catholic
schools
my administration is working to advance
school choice
it was my great honor to help the
catholic church with its schools
they needed hundreds of millions of
dollars nationwide
and i got it for him nobody else i got
it for him i hope you remember that on
november 3rd but
i got it for him and it was an honor to
do it i did it at the request of
cardinal dolan and others
of your leaders they really needed it we
took care of that situation
very important we are once again
standing with catholic charities and
health care providers
such as the little sisters of the poor
we've been with them all the way in this
long fight
we are fighting for catholic adoption
agencies and fighting hard
and we are defending the sacred right
to life remember that when you vote
that's so important and so important to
the supreme court
every child born and unborn is made in
the holy image of god
few institutions in history have done
more for new york
more for america or more for people of
the world
than the catholic church from the
parishes of this city
came the soldiers who fought to end
slavery the workers who raised up the
towering skyline of manhattan
the chaplains who landed on the beaches
of guadalcanal
the nuns who marched for civil rights
and the police officers and firefighters
who we love so much
who ran into the world trade center on
september 11
2001. now more than ever our nation
needs a renewal
of the values that this organization
promotes
and that the catholic faithful live out
each and
every day in peace we love the catholic
people we love the catholic religion
and above all we respect it greatly as
president i will always support you
in your effort to serve our fellow
citizens and to lift up
all humanity i will protect the catholic
church
and i will defend the rights of
religious believers of every race
religion
color and creed thank you once again to
the al smith memorial foundation
god bless you god bless new york and god
bless america
that was a mouthful that was really
quite something
you can watch that a few times to get
a grip of what he actually is saying yes
that was very very powerful and he's
addressing of course
cardinal dolan as well who is the head
of the knights of mata in the united
states not
worldwide but in the united states
and he's also well the catholic
representative for the armed forces
so this is really church and state
at the highest level yes and
he made it quite clear
that anti-catholic sentiment has to
end and that rome has played such a
pivotal role
in all of these issues and taking care
of the poor
and the soup kitchens and all of those
things many of them
are of course absolutely true so i want
to make it quite clear
nobody here in this forum
is against catholics no not the persons
no the people are
doing the best they can living
according to the light that they have
absolutely
so this is not about catholics this is
about
catholicism and this
is where the great danger lies
and we want to listen to another speech
that he
held very similar speech but just to get
the full picture he says a few things
that are slightly different
this was at the prayer breakfast yes
where
william bar william brought his speech
and he also got the honorary
award yes and we looked at that in the
in our last what's up
so let's just look at what donald trump
said at
that particular one
it is my great honor to address the
national catholic prayer breakfast
i want to thank my good friend leonard
leo
and the board members of this wonderful
breakfast
as well as of course the knights of
columbus
and congratulations to attorney general
bill barr
special man on receiving the annual
award
i grew up next to a catholic church in
queens new york and i saw how much
incredible work
the catholic church did for our
community these are
amazing people these are great great
people
catholic schools give many underserved
children
the chance to reach their god-given
potential catholics of all background
share the love of christ with the most
vulnerable as they
care for the elderly the homeless and
neighbors in need
our nation is strong because of
catholics and all people of faith
we believe in the joy of family the
blessing of freedom and the dignity of
work
and the eternal truth that every child
born and unborn
is made in the holy image of god i will
always protect the vital role of
religion
and prayer in american society and i
will always defend the sacred
right to life today i am announcing that
i will be signing the born alive
executive order
to ensure that all precious babies born
alive no matter their circumstances
receive the medical care that they
deserve this is our sacrosanct moral
duty
we are also increasing federal funding
for the neonatal research
to ensure that every child has the very
best chance to thrive and to grow
melania and i recently visited the
shrine of saint john paul
ii a man who had such a profound impact
on our country in the world
it was an incredible visit on his first
visit to the united states he concluded
his visit
to a catholic parish in harlem with
these words
let the good news of christ radiate from
your hearts
and the peace that he alone gives remain
forever
in your souls we are very grateful for
the millions of catholics across america
who live by these beautiful words and
bring hope and joy and light and grace
to the world thank you god bless you and
god bless america
and please take good care of
bill barr he's very important to all of
us
right so we now have
a picture of the view that the world
basically has of catholics and that the
president espouses in the united states
of america
and yes they do have humanitarian works
and they do have soup kitchens and they
do many good works
but that is not the issue the issue
lies much deeper and
the people in the world need to know
now i myself was raised catholic
and going through an atheistic
phase i actually became very catholic
again
for a short while until i discovered
some things which were very very
disturbing
not in what they do but in what they
believe
and in their history as to how they deal
with people that do not believe
as they believe yes i can i just say
that is what's important to me to take
out of these
especially trump speeches well biden as
well
and like you said we agree there's lots
of these wonderful people and what they
maybe do is wonderful
but he said we love the catholic
religion
yes and that is what we want to look at
so
why do people say
that if you speak against catholicism
these days you are a bigot
so let us just continue
and see what the real issue is
now i don't want to quote from an
adventist source
from the beginning so let's go to the
church of england
and in the late 1800s what did they
believe and why did they believe it
this is the book romanism and the
reformation
by h gratan guiness
he was a priest in the church of england
and he wrote in the foreword
the reformation of the 16th century
which gave
birth to protestantism was based on
scripture
it gave back the world the bible it
taught the scriptures
it exposed the errors and corruptions of
rome by the use of the sword of the
spirit
it applied the prophecies and accepted
their practical guidance
such reformation work requires to be
done afresh
we have suffered prophetic anti-papal
truth to be
too much forgotten this generation is
dangerously latitudinary and that's a
beautiful word
isn't it you must explain that but
well you have longitude and you have
latitude they're asleep
asleep they're asleep
indifferent to truth and error on points
on which scripture is tremendously
decided and
absolutely clear
the very worst thing that can happen to
an
individual is to be deceived yes
deception is worse than
blatant confrontation although this
deception led in many cases to open
confrontation as well
let me just go back to what martin
luther said
now this is an old book and i happen to
have an old copy
you get much more modern copies
not one that's falling apart like this
one
it's a very old book but
it smells like
like an untouched
um unmolested yeah it's yes it's
definitely unmolested
you know the very writings of this book
this is a series of lectures
that he gave on the roman question
and uh and this book is falling apart
it's
the magnificent book everybody should
read
romanism and the reformation
he writes in the
forward here lecture one the daniel pre
for view of romanism fifty years ago
the eminent statement sir robert peale
said with remarkable clear foresight
the day is not far distant and it may be
very near when we shall have to fight
the battle of the reformation
over again and he's right and 100
yes we have to know
why we believe what
we believe we have to be firm
the day has come this was written in
the late 1800s and we can see from the
speeches that we just heard
that the world has forgotten and the
entire protestant world
has been duped into following a
false prophetic teaching not the
teaching that they used to have
at all so when we when we
read through a book like this
it says here on page five we feel
constrained to renew the grand old
protest to which the world
owes its modern acquisition of liberty
knowledge peace and prosperity
yes we need we feel constrained
to renew the grand old protest
to which the world owes its modern
acquisitions of
liberty knowledge peace
and prosperity there is no peace in the
world today
and there is a decline in prosperity
it says here it is a fact
that though the canon of scripture was
closed ages before romanism began
to exist and 15 centuries before the
reformation
yet it presents the divine judgment
as to both the bible records the past
in its histories and the future in its
prophecies
which are simply history written
beforehand
very well put these these writers
are unbelievable
the reformation this is on page nine the
reformation was a return
to primitive or non-apostate
christianity that is
very nicely put accomplished between
three
and four centuries ago well now it's
five already
in this country in germany and some
other countries in europe
one feature of this great movement was
the abandonment of the use of
latin in public worship the translation
of the scriptures into the living
language
so that all nations might read the word
of god
in their own tongue and understand for
themselves its
sacred messages the names of luther
twingly erasmus tyndall knox calvin
latimer ridley cranmer hooper and others
are associated with this reformation
and then he goes into the book of daniel
and he talks about
the prophecies in the book of daniel
and he talks about the writings of paul
and he says the apostle
paul for vue on the other hand
gives the ecclesiastical character and
relationship
of this power referring
to the prophecies regarding
daniel and revelation now let me just
turn to the next chapter where he starts
talking about
let me just find it i have to page
carefully in this book
because it's falling apart it's a
beautiful book
here's lecture two and he gives
a whole expose of daniel chapter 7 say
the whole of daniel chapter 7 in the
chapter
and then he says on page 37 in these
verses you have the entire story of the
papacy
and what is more you have its future as
well as
its past the judgment of god
as to its moral character and deserts
you had learned the abc of the language
of the hieroglyphs
you would at once recognize that such
creatures
as are figures of godless empires so it
describes the empires as listed in
daniel chapter 7
and he says that these are symbols
of godless empires he also says it is
important with
that we should clearly grasp one great
historical fact
that is the rule of rome has never
since its first commence ceased to exist
save once for a very brief period during
the gothic
inquisition rome we repeat
he says has never ceased it was a
secular pagan power for
five or six centuries it has been
an ecclesiastical and apostate christian
power ever since apostate christian
prostate christian power
and then he describes the little horn of
daniel chapter 7.
we could go there i have the bible but
we don't want to give a bible study i
just want to
just say what the reformers view was on
this particular issue
and he talks about the little horn power
and he says the power
symbolized by the proud intelligent
blasphemous head-like little horn
of the roman beast to this he devotes on
the contrary
the great part of the prophecy
and i must ask you carefully to
note the various points that prove
that this horn to be the marvelous
prophetic
symbol or hieroglyph of the roman papacy
fitting it as one of chubb's keys fits
the lock
for which it is made perfectly and
in every part while it refuses
absolutely to adapt itself to any other
and well deniable undeniable and
deniable in fact some people have
actually worked out the statistics
and said that it is absolutely
impossible
i mean the chances are one to the number
of atoms in the entire
universe that one organization
could fulfill all of these prophecies
if it weren't a divinely inspired
prophetic scenario
and then he lists them and he lists a
few of them and he says
it says where it would arise in the body
of the fourth
empire in other words in the heart of
the roman
power in the amongst the powers of
europe
at the period of its origin soon after
the division of the roman territory into
ten kingdoms this is church of england
this is not adventism
it's nature different from the other
kingdoms though in some respects like
them
it was a horn that is a political entity
but with eyes and a mouth it would be a
kingdom like the rest the monarchy but
its
king would be overseers or bishops and
prophets
these people had insight now
the moral character boastful blasphemous
great word spoken against the most high
it's lawlessness it would claim
authority over times and laws
it would change god's laws it would
change god's times
its opposition to the saints it would be
a persecuting power
its duration time times and half a time
and here it says in this book i must
show it to you
1260 years
these people had prophetic insight and
the world has forgotten this
they they're looking for an antichrist
to come i just wanted to say that
and here is a system that ruled for all
those years
whose mortal wound would be healed
and the kings of the world and we just
listen to them yeah
there they are there they are will give
their power
unto the beast what did biden say
social doctrine is the social doctrine
of the roman catholic church is the one
that they want
implemented it's been the in his life
that's what and for 500 years
the reformation saw to it that catholic
social doctrine
would not be the rule of the land
i don't want to be mean
but look at the protestant countries and
look at the catholic countries
which ones were the prosperous ones yeah
the protestant ones and why are they so
rapidly in decline
because we're heading back to the same
old system and i wish the kings of the
world would study
history i wish they would understand
what the reformation is about this is
not about are you a nice guy
this is about what you believe yes
that's what
yeah yeah there are three central
pillars
that every christian denomination
that believed in the bible and the bible
and the bible alone
were absolutely firm on
the one is the supremacy of christ
that nobody comes to the father except
through jesus christ there is no other
name
under heaven and earth whereby you can
be saved
except the name christ jesus
that's that's an immovable pillar
the second one is that the bible
is the rule of faith the bible
and the bible alone is the rule
of faith if you have any extraneous
source
like the seventh adventists believe
that the writings of ellen g white are
in harmony with this word yeah her
writings
must be tested by this word exactly not
this word
tested by her writings so
the rule of faith remains the bible and
the bible alone
and ever since the inception of
christianity
there were people that stood for the law
and kept the sabbath
yeah the early christian church kept the
sabbath
and all of these things have been
changed
by the roman power and this
is where the era lies and we have to
look
at these historic events so we're not
going to go through the book
but just to show people that this is
what protestantism believed
and you can see this is an old book it's
falling apart
but to read what these people believed
is amazing and people
have forgotten it and it's important
also that
like you have mentioned before but we
are
not trying to degrade people
no you get
very nice atheists
as well oh you got so wonderful people
that are atheists
most of my colleagues were atheists and
some of them were wonderful people to be
with
so it's not about the people no it's
about the religion
because this is what will be playing the
the role
and this is what we have to talk about
this is what we have to talk about
so let us continue and see
what the real problem is and why
the world needs to be reminded over and
over again
because we are going to repeat history
and it's not going to be a beautiful
sight no
what was the central pillar of the
reformation
martin luther he was speaking about
justification
by faith alone
he said of this article nothing can be
yielded or surrendered nor can anything
be granted or permitted
contrary to the same this
is the first and chief article of
faith of protestantism
he said if the article of justification
is lost
all christian doctrine is lost at the
same time
this doctrine justification is the head
and the cornerstone it alone
begets nourishes builds preserves
and defends the church of god and
without
it the church of god cannot exist for
one
hour when the article of justification
has
fallen everything
has fallen in other words this is a
religious war
this is a war about salvation
in jesus christ and
this is what people do not understand if
i
accept the authority of a power
that undermines the authority of jesus
christ
then i'm serving an anti-christ
power yeah and it doesn't matter how
many times that specific power
elevates or is saying that they elevate
christ
yes they can mention the name of christ
all the time they can preach in the name
of christ but if they do not do
what he says then they are contrary to
the scriptures
so rome was the one who cursed
this doctrine of justification by faith
alone
anyone who says that sinners are
justified by
faith alone so as to mean that nothing
else is required to cooperate in
order and to obtaining the grace of
justification let him be an anathema
that's canon 9 and canon 14
anyone who says that sinners are
justified by the soul
imputation of the righteousness of
christ
or by the soul remission of sins without
the charity which is shed abroad in
their hearts by the holy ghost
without infused grace let him be an
anathema
so rome is literally saying that we
become
righteous instead of having an imputed
righteousness
an alien righteousness one that is
outside of ourselves we're just looking
at the core doctrine here
of course all the other doctrines go
along with that we can
speak about those as well
so when we come to the joint document
on justification which today
of course is the compromise yes because
you just read the council of trent yes
but then there's a lot of people that
say yeah but that vatican
ii council vatican ii
did not rescind a single
doctrine proclaimed at the council of
trent
and could not do so
because they were spoken excuted
infallibly yes if they had to rescind it
they would destroy the doctrine of the
infallibility of the roman catholic
church
so the doctrines as expounded
in the council of trent stand stand
just want to make that clear and we have
many bishops saying that bishop
schneider was one who said it
quite openly it doesn't matter what the
papacy
says as long as it doesn't say it
ex katatra it can go in any direction
what matters is what was said excuted
from
the bishop's chair
so here is the wording of the document
of the joint declaration between
protestantism and catholics
which was now to end the great rift
between them
and it states the following together we
confess
by grace alone in faith in christ's
saving
work and not because of any merit on our
part we are accepted by god and receive
the holy spirit who renews our hearts
while equipping and calling us
unto good works now this sounds
wonderful
but it is written by
a pen which has the sting of death in it
because this is catholic doctrine
disguised as protestant god
doctrine they're very clever with their
words
so we've discussed it before we don't
want to go into great detail but
we confess that by grace alone no
this is true that we are saved by grace
alone
but the issue is the grace can only be
applied
after faith yes faith
how do i be saved by faith in christ's
atoning blood right
because otherwise everybody can be saved
because of the grace can i give you
grace if you were mean to me sure i can
i can be gracious to you right i can be
gracious
can i save you no no
could you be saved by faith in me no no
it would be a pretty useless venture
right
so it shouldn't read by grace alone
it should read by faith alone because
without faith it is impossible
to please him by faith alone
in faith they say by grace alone in
faith in christ's saving work
no in christ's atonement
by his blood because they believe
of course that you are saved by works
and christ's good works are in this pot
called the treasury of merit but so are
the good works of mary and the saints
yes so they are just on a par
yeah and pope francis of course
loves to quote saint francis
and saint francis is the one that he is
following
and he is the hero of the story
it's a total pantheistic deity that they
are serving
and if you read his latest document
we'll go through it in
in a future what's up we'll look at some
of the issues but
this pantheistic deity that was
so revered by saint francis
is the hero of the system of pope
francis
and we've also where's jesus yeah
remember we looked at that document also
for the jubilee for the earth
and that was a protestant document yes
and it is the same language this
fantastic language absolutely so
this is a a misquoting
of the doctrine of justification if it
had read
by faith alone in the atoning
sacrifice of jesus christ then it would
have been fine
but then it continues and not because of
any merit on our part we are accepted by
god and receive the holy spirit who
renews our heart
while equipping and calling us unto good
works
that of course is not justification
that's sanctification
so this is a mixture of sanctification
and justification with a
misrepresentation of justification
and protestants think it's wonderful
yeah they signed
they signed so this is a very wily foe
we have to be very careful how we go
about it
zenit news reports in its article on po
benedict's speech on papal primacy
titled the world scene from rome
benedict 16
highlights first century papal primacy
because this is the other issue
the reformation said christ is the head
of the church
the church of scotland said we have no
king
but jesus right when they rejected the
british rule
and the british monarch same here
it's a bit contradictory to what the
jews said that
jesus crucifixion they they said we have
no king but caesar yeah you're right
so what did he have to say there now
this is bringing it just into modern
times because the question is
always has rome changed rome cannot
change
its doctrine doesn't allow it to be
changed
it cannot rescind an ex-categorized
statement without rescinding papal
infallibility
can't do it this is a very um
serious matter because most
denominations and people say rome has
changed yes that's right
there are a lot of people even in our
own ranks that say
that rome has changed it has not
changed and here are some statements as
we will see this is now
pope benedict i mean he's still alive
right correct
technically speaking he's still apollo
yes
already in the first century popes
exercised their primacy
over the other churches benedict the
16th
said the holy father explained this on
wednesday at the
general audience which he dedicated to
pope
saint clement of rome the third
successor of peter saint clement's
letter clarifies the distinction between
hierarchy and laity you see the roman
catholic church
raised the hierarchy of the church above
the laity
the bible makes no such distinction no
in the modern translations
they have to violate the grammar in
order to make that distinction when
there is no
distinction we've talked about that
before
so we must be very careful so firstly
they believe in this hierarchy
they have elevated themselves
and he said the clear distinction
between the lay people
and the hierarchy does not mean in any
way
a contra position but only the organic
connection of a body of an
organism with different functions
they always speak in such flowery
language
but what he's basically saying i'm your
boss
in fact the church is not a place for
confusion
and anarchy we need a boss
where someone can do whatever he wants
at any time each one in this
organism with an articulated structure
practices his ministry according to the
vocation received
as pertains to the heads of the
communities
specifies clearly the doctrine of
apostolic succession
in other words that the authority came
down the line
which they believed was given to peter
but paul rebuked peter and james
yes it was at the council of
paul rebuked jerusalem absolutely
so they believe in this power coming
down the line
and then he added the laws that regulate
this derive from god himself
in an ultimate analysis i
am the boss god said so
i rule by divine right
that's what he's saying that's what he's
saying
the father sent jesus christ who in turn
sent the apostles these then sent out
the first heads of the communities and
established that they would be followed
by worthy men
well we see in history how worthy some
of these men were
in the system the church is above
all a gift of god and not a creature of
ours
the pope contended and therefore
this sacramental structure this is very
important language
not only guarantees the common order but
also
the precedence of the gift of god that
we all need
now that is astounding
he claims that the fact that he is the
head of the church
is a sacramental structure
now in catholic thinking a sacrament
is something that leads to salvation
so in other words what he is saying is
that the recognition of the papacy
is absolutely necessary for salvation
that's what he's saying and this is
the modern pope who's still alive today
who says that it's absolutely necessary
in
very very disguised language
to be subject to the roman pontiff
the acceptance of pipel primacy is thus
according to the present pope a
sacramental structure this is me writing
now
which in catholic thinking makes it a
salvation issue
this is not a 19th century obscure quote
but demonstrates clearly that
rome has not changed absolutely
accepting jesus is a salvation issue not
accepting an earthly impostor who takes
upon themselves the prerogatives of
christ
benedict also elevates the clergy and
assigns it a mediatorial role
just as the medieval church did
this comes from the vatican webpage
and we just want to make sure that
people know that this is not an obscure
source right
so this is a very serious issue it has
to do
with salvation do i have to accept the
primacy of the pope in order to be saved
that's according to the bible did jesus
use an intermediary
while he was on earth to convey
forgiveness of sins
to anyone that he came into contact with
no no not at all so if he didn't do it
then why should he do it now
this is the address of his holiness
benedict to the members of the episcopal
conference
of portugal on their ad limina visit
he says it gives a great joy for me to
receive you today in the house of peter
who by the grace of god are solid
pillars of
that bridge which you are called to be
and to create between humanity and its
supreme destiny the most holy trinity
have you have you thought about the
statement like that this is benedict
speaking
he's saying that the clergy is the
bridge
to heaven in other words you can't get
there without the clergy
so christ's pushed aside
i actually want to remind president
donald trump who claims to be a
protestant
that if this is the claim of the papacy
to stand
on that bridge is a very very very
dangerous thing to do if i had to rely
on the clergy to bring me to the
promised land
i would be in serious serious trouble
the only source that i can rely on
for correct information is this one
the bible and the bible alone
and if i read a book like this by gratin
guinness this ancient book
if it's not in harmony with this book
then i have to lay this one aside and
this one is my authority
the same for the writings of ellen g
white or anybody else exactly
that is the filter this is the photo
the ultimate filter but he continues
he says he is the bridge and he says it
is no longer i
who live but christ who lives in me and
then he takes
this text and he says a concrete sign of
this incarnation
is the pouring out of christ's life
which flows
forth from me benedict speaking
into the lives of others this is because
i cannot possess
christ just for myself i can belong to
him only in union with all those who
have become
or will become his own we become
one body completely joined in a single
existence through whom
through him no not christ through him
and through the clergy so this
structure is the means to salvation
and that is not biblical there is
no other name under heaven and earth
whereby you may be saved and this
is the danger
let's just make sure well here is
malachi
martin's book and
it is rich church poor church
now he was a jesuit priest so
let's see what he has to say he
maintains that the pontiff
is the sole living representative of god
amongst men is endowed with absolute
authority to teach
god's salvation as revealed through his
son jesus christ
who was and is god himself made man
catholic teachings holds that any roman
catholic
any non-catholic christian or any
non-christian of whatever other religion
receives god's salvation receives it
through the spiritual
office of that one man in rome
and the merits of his church of
believers
that's pretty clear yes so
even if people would like to say that
i misrepresented what benedict says
i did not because here
is the absolute statement by a jesuit
that this is exactly what he meant
every single doctrine that is held
by roman catholicism and that has been
incorporated into protestantism
or not expunged out of protestantism
is is a doctrine against the bible
you can you can take any doctrine take
the doctrine of baptism
the baptism is for believers
if you believe with your whole heart
then you may
by the way that verse has also been
removed in modern translation which is
exceedingly vexing
but the issue is this
baptism was to keep the world out of the
church
by introducing infant baptism which rome
did
it brought the world into the church
and made it subject to the church
if you take any one of those doctrines
if you take the mass
any one of them we'll look at some of
them we don't have to go
into all of them but they're all
contrary to the word of god
which should really tell you something
and we'll also i'll put the link again
for the what's up profs that you did on
the doctrine of the serpent yes
what clearly shows their teachings now
when the kings of the world give their
power
unto the beast which the bible says they
will do
and what are they doing they are placing
yes their authority under the authority
of the bishop of wrong yes
that's very clear and who have you
sidelined then
jesus jesus christ now
if jesus christ is someone who must be
accepted by faith by a personal choice
then you cannot force that conscience
so i'm not going against any other
religion
i'm not trying to force any other
to believe like i believe or like you
believe
but what i'm saying that if a bible
study
reveals something to you and you do not
act
upon it then it be for you sin
then it'd be for your sin they would
change times and laws they would change
the commandments of god did rome change
the commandments of god
yes absolutely that shocked me i was a
roman catholic
and i asked the roman catholic priest to
come to my house
and say excuse me please explain to me
why
rome changed the commandments of god
his answer to me was i'm not into
scripture
which made me almost fall off my chair
and i said but you're a priest
he says i'm not into scripture we have
specialists that deal with scripture
obviously distorting it right obviously
if he's a priest and he's not into
scripture what about the
normal member of the church absolutely
that must be terrible then yes i grew up
with a catechism in my hand
not with the bible i remember you had a
story that you were looking for a bible
at one stage because there wasn't one in
the house no there wasn't one in the
house
correct but this is this is catholic
teaching
and this is contrary to the word of god
maguire's catechism puts it this way
bishops and priests of the church are
called
other christs they alone have the power
to represent or to take the place of
christ
in preaching his gospel and in offering
his sacrifice
for the glory of god and the salvation
of men
now we read benedict's statement
and it's published on the vatican web
page
which i said was not an obscure source
it's very current
in terms of history yes has rome changed
no no through his ordination a priest is
supposed to receive a special
supernatural powers particularly to
change bread and wine into the body
and blood of christ in the holy
sacrifice of the mass and to forgive
sins in the sacrament of
penance whose prerogative is it to
forgive sins
jesus christ jesus christ don't they
take the prerogative of christ upon
themselves here yep
didn't even the jews say who can forgive
sins but god alone
exactly and to say that you change
the bread and the wine into the body and
blood of christ
then the created being becomes the
creator
of the creator of the creator who's
higher then
the middle being
absolutely in 1988
the free presbyterian church of
scotland's clerk to the synod reverend
donald
mclane's comment in his letter to the
times
regarding the economical movement which
now
got rid of all of these differences
because even pope francis says
set doctrine aside and
we gave two what's-ups on the doctrine
of the serpent yeah
so this is a very important issue
he said the economical movement which
you praise is the greatest disaster to
affect the christian church this century
just take note who this is this is the
free pressed preterion church of
scotland
clerk to the senate the reverend
donald mclean and he said it's the
greatest disaster
it has reduced the professing churches
of this country to a collection of
bloodless
spineless and boneless organizations
which can hardly raise a whimper on the
side of christ and his truth
small wonder that evil progresses as it
does
in spiritual darkness becomes more
intense as the years go by
you appear to regard a body of
professing christians of sober conduct
and
deep spirituality of mind as fanatical
bigoted doesn't pope francis say the
same
yep doesn't he talk about christian
fundamentalists who believe the bible
absolutely then you qualify then you are
a fundamentalist and a terrorist
if this be so then the imminent men of
god such as
john knox in scotland john calvin and
martin luther on the continent and
archbishop cranmer in england
were bigots in their contest with the
errors of potpourri
we are glad to be in such company
the issue is one of faith
and doctrine this this person
writes about 100 years after
the that book and it's after this one he
has the same sentiment
he believes the same thing
we have allowed ourselves to be duped
into no longer recognizing the wiley foe
by the way didn't presidents of the
united states like abraham lincoln
warn against this power and the jesuits
yes it didn't uh samuel moss
warn against this power didn't many
prelates and preachers
warn against this power why have we
forgotten
it seems we need to be reminded over and
over again
so we have discussed now some of the
quotes out of
gratin guinness and
we looked at the issue in the bible
yeah through gratangina's writings
and now we've also looked at what
benedict what's
what he is current and so on let's look
at the spirit of prophecy which is in
absolute harmony what protestantism used
to believe
so we're not quoting a a source that is
out of harmony with the bible here
the apostle paul in his second letter to
the thessalonians foretold the great
apostasy
which would result in the establishment
of the papal power
he declared that the day of christ would
not come except there come a falling
away first and that man of sun be
revealed the son of perdition
who opposes and exalteth himself above
all that is called
god or that is worshiped so that he as
god
sitteth in the temple of god showing
himself that he
is god by the way rotten guinness has
a section of this verse in this book
in which he clearly states that the
temple of god
is the church and then he
quotes paul where he says to the
corinthians and to the ephesians
you are the temple of the living god
and then he says the man of sin sits in
the christian
church today in a literal temple
in he says it like that yes he says not
in
a temple of stone so
there is this marvelous
synchronism between what the reformers
wrote
and what and what what we read here in
the writings of ellen g
white it's exactly the same and
furthermore the apostle warns his
brethren that the mystery of iniquity
does already work
thessalonians 2 3 4 and 7.
even at that early date he saw creeping
into the church
errors that would prepare the way for
the development of the papacy
little by little at first in stealth and
silence and then more
openly as it increased in strength and
gained control of the minds of men
the mystery of iniquity carried forward
its deceptive and blasphemous work
the way in which these books are written
is just amazing to me and when you read
those old reformers
and you you put them next to each other
the spirit
is identical there was a man
that was preaching on another place
continent or country
at the same time as luther and
his the people were asking him and
telling him you sound just like luther
and he said i don't know luther but
if he's preaching the same as i it must
be the spirit that's leading
absolutely absolutely so
almost imperceptibly the customs of
hedonism found their way into the
christian church
the spirit of compromise and conformity
was restrained for a time by the fierce
persecutions which the church endured
under paganism
so the church was pure in the beginning
and kept pure
because you weren't going to join an
organization that was going to be
persecuted right
unless you had a very profound reason
but as persecution ceased and
christianity
entered into the courts and palaces of
kings
she laid aside the humble simplicity of
christ and his apostles for the pomp and
pride
of pagan priests and rulers and
in place of the requirements of god she
substituted human theories and
traditions
this is the issue so when donald trump
said that we cannot tolerate
anti-catholic
rhetoric then he has
the mindset of today where the history
has been
wiped out yeah he must study history
and go back to the source and listen to
what the early reformers said
and to what the early presidents like
lincoln
had to say i mean there's a book written
on this issue
by a catholic priest who became a
protestant father chineke
and the book is 50 years in the church
of rome
where he talks about the assassination
of lincoln
and how the jesuits were the ones that
was behind it
people should read books like this 50
years in the church of rome by father
chineke
get all of those books and read them
read
the fox's book of martyrs that's a very
very heavy book to read you you'll
probably like i did
you'll read the first three chapters and
then you want to cry and put it down for
a while
yes absolutely because the people don't
understand
why and i think a lot of people don't
understand why we continually want to
make prominent why the roman church
yes they're constantly saying i'm
anti-catholic yes
i'm anti-catholic doctrine yes
because it is an antichrist doctrine and
people need to be warned
it's never changed never changed never
never the nominal
conversion of constantine in the early
part of the 4th century caused
great rejoicing and the world arrayed in
robes of
righteousness who walked into the church
now the work of corruption rapidly
progressed
paganism while appearing to be
vanquished became the conqueror
her spirit controlled the church her
doctrines ceremonies and superstitions
were incorporated into the faith and
worship
of the professed followers of christ
this was later recorded as tradition
and in roman catholic thinking tradition
is the context in which the bible must
be interpreted
no tradition must be tested by the
scripture and not the other way around
this is spirit of prophecy volume 4.
this is basically the great controversy
in its early form
i prefer reading the old ones because
they still call a spade a spade
this compromise between paganism and
christianity resulted in the development
of the man of sin
foretold in prophecy as opposing and
exalting himself
above god that gigantic system of false
religion
is a masterpiece of satan's power
a monument of his effort to seat himself
upon the throne
to rule the earth according to his will
and when the world gave its power unto
this papal system
paganism had rule
over the church and the pontifex maximus
was nothing other than the old pagan
god king and still is today
it is one of the leading doctrines of
romanism that the pope is the visible
head of the universal church we just saw
that benedict made it very clear that
that was the case
invested with supreme authority over
bishops and pastors in
all the world they even went so far
malachi
martin said all other christian
denominations
and all other religions yeah
that's interesting that it puts them
as the soul entity
yes and benedict benedict also
said other churches are no
sisters of ours they're not sister
churches
they were children children and the
bible clearly says
that the great apostate system says i
will not
suffer loss of children they shall
return
unto me and what donald trump said
in his speech is a fulfillment of
prophecy
i wish the world would see it no it's
interesting
you've had all the persecutions in the
middle ages
that the church forced you to be part of
her
and then it changed that now they're
willingly
going back absolutely this is this is
the power of the economical movement and
the main
reason is because they forgot history
yes and because they're setting aside
doctrine
correct and pope francis clearly said
set aside doctrine otherwise we can't
have unity yes doctrine's not important
but the bible says take heed of the
doctrine
take heed of the doctrine so
in other words when he takes this title
he assumes infallibility
thus the same claim urged by satan in
the wilderness of temptation
is urged still by him through the church
of rome and vast numbers are ready to
yield him homage
when you accept this power you are
yielding homage to satan
because you bypass jesus christ that's a
very serious
a very serious issue
god has never given a hint in his word
that he has appointed any man to be the
head of the church
satan well knew that the holy scriptures
would enable
men to discern his deceptions and
withstand
his power it was by the word that even
the savior of the world had resisted his
attacks
and so rome went about to
change the scriptures when they couldn't
suppress it
when the death sentence no longer worked
because their power was taken away after
they received a mortal wound in 1798
they choose chose another root yes and
morse
they talk about the bible they have so
many versions that you don't know what
to read
read that which comes from
the received text and you will
be reading the word of god amen
in order for satan to maintain his sway
over men and establish the authority of
the papal usurper he must keep them in
ignorance of the scripture the bible
would exalt god and place finite men in
their true position therefore its sacred
truths must be concealed
and suppressed so the people were
forbidden to
read it or to have it in their houses
and thus the pope came to be almost
universally acknowledged as the vice
regent of god on earth endowed with
supreme authority over church and state
yeah those days people
weren't allowed or didn't read their
bibles at all
the uh church the priests
gave them the word yes because it was
only in
in the foreign languages only the latin
bible was available to them
the greek manuscripts were in the church
of the east
and not available to them the detector
of error having been removed that's the
bible
satan worked according to his will
prophecy had declared that the papacy
was to think
times and laws now this is how they
worked
this work it was not slow to attempt
to afford converts from hedonism
a substitute for the worship of idols
and thus to promote their nominal
acceptance of christianity
the adoration of images and relics were
gradually
introduced into the christian worship
but then of course the second
commandment was in their way right
so we don't have to read at all but they
had to
expunge the second commandment
from the law of god so they took it out
but now they only had nine
so they split the second the tenth one
into two
so that they could have ten and uh
that that surprised me when i when i
discovered these things in the bible
with what
right did they take a commandment out of
the bible
with what right like we've read in the
previous statements
the church believe it's got the power
above the bible yes
i can just change it just go and change
it
so the spirit of concession to paganism
opened the way for still further
disregard of heaven's authority satan
tampered with the fourth commandment
also
and assad to set aside the ancient
sabbath the day which god had blessed
and sanctified i know we've spoken about
this a lot
but if people would just look at the
word of god
did the early christian church keep the
sabbath
yes they rested according to the
commandment did jesus keep the sabbath
yes
yes that paul keep the sabbath yes
history tells us that the early
christian church kept the sabbath
the sabbath was preached in many places
it was kept in england it was only after
the uh
after the year 600 and something
that roman people came to england and
found
certain people keeping the sabbath and
they ward against it
the celtic church kept the sabbath the
world engines kept the sabbath
the valdances kept the sabbath it's
amazing africans kept the sabbath and
the missionaries
that came here changed
yes then to keep not to keep the sabbath
when the jesuits came to india
with the vasco de gama they found the
thomasite christians keeping the sabbath
the sabbath was the day which the
christians kept
china kept the sabbath so it was but all
places in china so this change was not
at first attempted
openly in the first centuries the true
sabbath had been kept by
all christians that the intention
of the people might be called to the
sunday it was made a festival
in honor of the resurrection of christ
with what authority
but churches are the authority of the
church
but the honor show in this day was not
yet sufficient to prevent
christians from regarding the truth
sabbath as the holy of the lord
another step must be taken the false
sabbath must be exalted to inequality
with the true
a few years after the issue of
constantine's decree and by the way
he was still a pagan when he made the
decree
for sunday worship and his coin
had mitra on the one side and
christian symbols on the other side
right
the bishop of rome conferred on sunday
the title the lord's day
with what authority again the churches
the churches
thus the people were gradually led to
regarded as possessing a degree of
sacredness
still the original sabbath was kept
the arts deceiver had not completed his
work he was resolved to gather the
christian world under his banner and to
exercise his power through his wise
region the proud pontiff
who claimed to be represented of christ
through half-converted pagans ambitious
prelates and world-loving judgment he
accomplished his purpose
so they held vast councils and
eventually they pushed it
further and further and further
and thus the pagan festival came finally
to be honored as a divine
institution while the bible sabbath was
pronounced the relic of judaism
and its observers were declared to be
accursed
the great had apostate succeeded in
exalting himself above
all that is called god or that is
worship
just think of it infant baptism
then the change of the sabbath it
changed god's laws images were back in
the church
relics were being venerated people that
were dead were exalted
to the position of sainthood as
mediators for humanity the whole
the whole issue of salvation was changed
and people think because they mentioned
the name of christ that they are a
christian power it's actually
if you really go through especially
total onslaught and so on
you see that the it's just it's a pagan
religion
absolutely it's just the names that's
changed even the gods
that were pagan just got a name change
and now became christian and they kept
the same days
they kept the same days and they changed
the calendar
to bring it in harmony with the pagan
feast days
changed times and laws
so the great apostate has succeeded in
exalting himself above all that is
called god
or that is worship he had dared to
change the
only precept of the divine law that
unmistakingly points all mankind to the
true and living god
isn't it interesting that wrong
says that the adventists are the only
body of christian that can find
no evidence in this word of god
that they should keep the sunday
and in fact they say they are the only
consistent protestants yeah
now i'm sad to say that many even in our
own ranks
are losing the plot they cannot
see that rome has not
changed and even
when you show it the economical movement
has had such an
impact on humanity because we have to do
it for the common good yes
the scary thing is there's so many
things that's pulling the people away
from the true
focus that you have to have to see
that the antichrist system is still
going to rule this whole thing yes and
that means jesus christ this sideline
my salvation does not lie in social
doctrine
that is something for this world and for
this kingdom
and this kingdom is coming to an end so
to put my energy
into a social doctrine i'm not
against fairness for all people
absolutely
nothing to do with it but that's not
where my salvation lies
my salvation lies in my faith in jesus
christ
and my faith in jesus christ and his
saving grace for
all humanity makes all who
accept his promise and his salvation
my brothers and my sisters and that's
what makes us brothers and sisters
yes not we've got a common cause
no because that common cause can change
from area to areas and that's what's
happening now
the common cause like we've seen with
that um
whole ecumenical gathering the return
the common causes we have to get guard
back into the country so it doesn't
matter what
how in what way we do but for what
purpose must he come back into countries
so that you can set up an earthly
kingdom
which is not what is going to be
destroyed yes that's why you have to
understand the
image of daniel
absolutely all right let's continue
so eventually rome took the papal seat
and ruled supreme for 1260 years
from 5 38 a.d to 1798
and then were fulfilled the words of
jesus you shall be betrayed both by
parents and brethren and kinsfolk and
friends
and some of you they shall cause to be
put to death and you shall be hated for
by all men for my name's sake
persecution upon the faithful with
greater fury
than ever before and the world became a
vast
battlefield this is what happened
and then the woman fled into the
wilderness the church
the true church of god fled away the
valdez's
they fled away and worshiped god
according to their conscience and
according to the word of god
the advancing centuries witnessed the
constant
increase of error in the doctrines put
forth
from rome so it didn't stop it was not
just
an instant thing it was a progression
even before the establishment of the
papacy the teachings of heathen
philosophers
had received attention and exerted an
influence in the church
today what the roman church believes in
is greek philosophy
the whole system of natural law is based
on greek philosophy
in fact it's interesting that in
revelation chapter 13
the body of this structure
is given a greek body
it was a leopard body so greek
philosophy is the basis
of roman catholicism it's not the gospel
it's paganism
yeah and now we can see it clearly
in the encyclical absolutely
one of the doctrines of course which is
very important is natural immortality
and consciousness in death this doctrine
laid the foundation upon which
rome established the invocation of
saints and the adoration of the virgin
mary
isn't that interesting that
donald trump went and knelt in that
shrine
in front of this huge relief of
john paul ii that's a dead man
who knows nothing who has nothing to do
on this earth anymore and he's sleeping
in the grave until judgment day right
and he received from a catholic priest a
statue of mary to place into the white
house
that is idolatry there is something
forbidden in the word of god
that is part of the commandment that
rome
expunged from the ten commandments and
they don't see it
is it not our duty to warn the world
that a false system of worship
has set itself up as an authority
and will introduce its form of
government
and enforce it upon the world
yes and it's also our duty to warn
people
don't be blinded by what
perceives to be christian
exactly it looks good and we and we so
i mean the conservative christian people
so want to get rid of all this
secularism and all this
that they want to go with this but this
is
not a christian institution in christian
teachings our catholic friends
that don't know these things
we are not allowed to according to papal
theology today
to tell them these things because that's
proselytizing
and we're not supposed to do that you're
supposed to leave
everyone where he is in the latest
encyclical that the pope just wrote
on brotherly fraternity he clearly
mentions the muslim world he mentions
the jewish world
he mentions the various thinkers of the
world he even mentions
the bishops in south africa and says we
must
all these religions and all these people
and all these migrants and everybody
with different ideas
tolerate each other and live together
and basically leave them where they are
that is religious liberty but to preach
to them
and to try to convert them
is something that you should not do but
the bible clearly says go ye
into all the world and preach the gospel
what is the gospel the gospel is the
good news of salvation in jesus christ
that means that every roman catholic
should be confronted with the gospel of
jesus christ that he can make an
informed choice
now in my own case if i had not been
confronted with the gospel of jesus
christ
and the word of god i would have still
been where i was
and i would not have known the beauty
of the plan of salvation i would not
have understood
what is happening in the world
the word of god is the basis upon which
we must make our decisions
and there are many other issues that we
could talk on
the issue of indulgences
the issue of purgatory
we've discussed these things before in
what's a prof we don't have to do that
these are not christian doctrines these
are pagan doctrines these are greek
philosophies what are they doing in the
christian world
how can two sit together lest they
agreed how can a protestant christian
say that he accepts roman catholicism
as a christian form of worship
on the basis of them using the name
jesus christ and even talking about
jesus christ as divinity
but working through the priest working
through the saints working through mary
and bypassing jesus christ and making
the church the bridge builder
these doctrines are a
travesty of judge justice when it comes
to the word of god
and then the selling of indulgences by
such means that rome fill her coffers
and sustain the magnificent luxury and
vice of the pretended representatives of
him who had
not where to lay his head not to speak
of the millions
that were sacrificed in this war of
faith so i want to
just tell the presidents of the world
and the people of the world that we need
to study
the bible and need to study
what the reformers believe we need to
take the dust of books such as this that
still
clearly spoke about what the word
had to say so here's the question
in this age of echomanism we are not
supposed to say
anything derogatory about any other
religion
the modern phrase is
don't judge me don't judge me
are we not supposed to preach the word
of god
are we not to lead people to the
fountain
of living water
so what does this church
stand for and even in our rank own ranks
there are many voices
which say we should we should
lower the rhetoric we shouldn't say any
of these things
but let's read some of the statements in
the spirit of prophecy
called to expose the man of sin
in the very time in which we live the
lord has called his people
and has given them a message to bear he
has called them to expose the wickedness
of the man of sin
who has made the sunday lord distinctive
power
who has thought to change times and laws
and to oppress the people of
god who stand firmly to honor him by
keeping the only true sabbath the
sabbath of creation as holy unto the
lord
it's our duty to speak about these
things
and it's not only the spirit of
prophecies that says so
the bible says so and the bible says you
will be persecuted when you do it
you will be persecuted and the bible
also says if you don't do it
then the blood is on your head
we are to give the people the warning
contained in revelation
the truth in regard to the sabbath of
the lord is to proclaim
it's not just the sabbath that's
important it's what
is built into the sabbath the worship of
the true god
it's the sign that you accept him as
your authority
and not some earthly imposter
the bible says that the kings of the
world will give their power unto the
beast
we've listened to these speeches now
this is what we're talking about
and why is it such a serious matter
well here's an interesting statement it
comes from letters and manuscripts and
it says
the power which has the deepest inward
corruption
will make the greatest display
and will clothe itself with the most
elaborate
signs of power the bible plainly
declares that this
covers a corrupt and deceiving
wickedness
upon a foreign was the name written
mystery babylon the great the mother of
harlots and the abomination of the earth
that's pretty harsh language what is it
that gives
its kingdom this power
protestantism a power which while
professing to have
the temper and spirit of a lamb and to
be allied to heaven speaks with the
voice of a dragon it is moved by a power
from beneath
protestantism will give the power back
to the beast it had separated itself
it it'll give it back and look at what's
happening and we can see it in the
speeches
the roman church now presents a fair
front to the world
covering with apologies her record of
horrible cruelties
she has closed the self in christ-like
garments but she's
unchanged every principle of the papacy
that existed in past ages
exists today the doctrines devised in
the darkest
ages are still held that none deceive
themselves
we cannot call it the christian power
the
pope francis in quite recently
and in a few times already apologized
made apologize to the vuldances yes
is it a deep rooted apology
no according to this definitely
definitely not the papacy that
protestants are now so
ready to honor is the same that ruled
the world in the days of the reformation
when when of god stood up at the peril
of their lives to expose her iniquity
she possesses the same pride and
arrogant assumption that
lauded it over kings and princes we can
see this
and claim the prerogative of god
her spirit is no less cruel and despotic
now than when she crushed out human
liberty and slew the saints of the most
high
the papacy is just what prophecy
declared that she would be
the apostasy of the latter times
it is part of a policy to assume the
character which will best accomplish her
purpose but beneath the variable
appearance of the chameleon
she conceals the invariable venom
of the serpent shall this power
whose record for a thousand years is
written in the blood of the saints be
now acknowledged as part of the
church of christ
it is not without reason that the claim
has been put forth in
protestant countries that catholicism
differs
less widely from protestantism than in
former times
there has been a change but the change
is
not in the papacy catholicism indeed
resembles
much of the protestantism that now
exists
because protestantism has so greatly
degenerated since the days of the
reformers
what did we read in the beginning yep
dangerously latitudinary yes
dangerously leslie and we will have to
redo the reformation we will have to
fight this battle
all over again this is
exactly where we are
the church that holds the word of god is
irreconcilably separated
from wrong protestants were once thus
apart from the great church
of apostasy but they have approached
much more near to her
and are still in the path of
reconciliation to the church of rome
rome never changes
her principles have not altered in the
least
she has not lessened the breach between
herself and protestants
they have done all the advancing
but what does this argue for the
protestantism of this day
it is the rejection of bible truth which
makes
men approach to infidelity it is a
backsliding church
that lessens the distance between itself
and the papacy
these are strong words but it is the
truth
i think we have made our point we don't
have to
continue along this vein i think it's
pretty clear
and i think it's also pretty clear what
the sentiments
of the two candidates for president
exactly
so we are living in a time of
prophetic fulfillment and this is a
warning
to the world and we want to end with a
very
uplifting statement it comes from
testimonies for the church volume 5 page
and it reads when the religion of christ
is
most held in contempt when his law
is most despised then should our zeal be
the warmest
and our courage and firmness the most
unflinching
to stand in defense of truth and
righteousness when the majority forsake
us
to fight the battles of the lord when
champions of few
this will be our test at this time we
must gather
warmth from the coldness of others
courage from their cowardice
and loyalty from their treason the
nation will be
on the side of the great rebel
leader i think it has become clear
that the nation is on the side
of the great rebel leader may god give
his people wisdom
and may we wake up to warn humanity for
what is about to transpire
never before in the history of the
united states
have speeches such as we discussed today
been made from the highest office of the
united states of america
by both candidates in the presidential
run
may god help us let's pray
heavenly father prophecy is fulfilling
before our eyes
and a world needs to be warned help us
to be awake and alert for the times that
are coming
and to warn those who are in the valley
of decision
is my prayer in jesus name amen
you for watching this video to subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you